well let's get the latest analysis of
the situation on the ground in ukraine
i'm joined now by the defense and
security analyst uh michael clark uh
michael we've got a map here at the
start of all of ukraine what is the the
latest uh
on the ground there as we push into the
fifth week yeah story the last couple of
days is uh ukrainian counter-attacks
they're they're really doing very well
so they're counter-attacking in the
northeast and the north-west of kiev the
russians are digging in going very
defensive the russians are being pushed
back a bit from mikolai of the
ukrainians are keeping them away from
the from the city which is the gateway
to odessa which must be the main
strategic objective and the ukrainians
say they think they'll retake kersham
which is the only city of the russians
significant city the russians have
really got that may be a bit of a
stretch actually but we'll see that the
ukrainians are very confident the fresh
development this afternoon as well some
what feels like targeted missile attacks
uh to to the west of the country yeah i
mean
the the russians are using the missiles
to probe for supply routes and depots
and the sort of stuff that's coming in
through from poland so every time they
think they see something around lev i
think they go for it in terms of on the
ground focus uh russia now saying
they're going to focus in on the don
bass region if they are saying that
we've only got one statement i mean joe
biden has said he's not sure that that's
true i know the rest of us are not sure
that's true but it would make some
military sense the russians are far too
widely dispersed around the country they
can't achieve their objectives the
donbass the area in the black here the
two oblasts of luhansk and donetsk um
they never occupied more than a third of
it the separatists they've got about
half of it now if they concentrated
their forces and they've got 10 more
battalion
tactical groups forming if they sent
most of them 7 000 men to the area they
could probably hold the donbass they
could probably take it so that makes a
certain amount of military sense it's
far far less than putin started with but
there you go of course they've held
crimea since 2014 this focus now on the
east is part of that and aim to try and
connect uh this red shaded area together
yes it could be i mean the idea of a
land corridor between the donbass and
crimea which has been illegally occupied
since 2014 makes again a certain amount
of sense and they might want to go for
that although they might have to pull
back from kershaw and mikolai which they
really can't hold probably
even if they get all of this they will
have to fight to keep it because the
ukrainians their tails are up they're
not going to settle for anything less
than throwing the russians out as far as
they can from these territories and so
they'll probably keep attacking them if
they can marry apollo keep focusing that
part alas yes the uh the tragedy of
mario paul just keeps unfolding they
won't surrender there so it will go the
way it goes michael for now thanks so
much